[Music]
it's Tuesday September 16th wait
good morning Hank it's Tuesday September
18th Hank I really like what you read
yesterday and I thought it had great
potential and I hope that one day you
finish it and speaking of finishing
guess who finished a revision of Paper
Towns hint it's me Hank I'm so like
happy and relieved and excited I just
want to like yes yes I got to get in
shape man happy dancing takes it out of
me Hank in other news I've been thinking
a lot lately about Chris Crocker who
made a YouTube video recently in which
big and apparently real tears are cried
in defense of Britney Spears Hank it's
extremely difficult for me to explain to
you how little I care about Britney
Spears I mean I feel bad for her in the
sense that she is a narcissistic drug
addict but I also think that there are a
lot of narcissistic drug addicts who
don't have 50 million dollars and so I
choose to devote most of my feeling bad
for narcissistic drug addict resources
to those people but anyway Hank Chris
Crocker feels bad for Britney and Who am
I to judge I felt bad for Kurt Cobain
when I was Chris's age although in my
defense every time Kurt Cobain coughed
he spit out more talent than Britney
Spears has ever possessed so but Hank
the thing about Chris Crocker that
people keep noticing is that Chris is a
young openly gay person who doesn't do a
very good job of fulfilling our
expectations of how boys should act and
talk and think and for some reason
people either find that absolutely
hilarious or completely offensive Hank I
know a lot of people think that gender
differences are inborn and that men are
from Mars and women are from Venus and
there's no way to travel from Mars to
Venus or from Venus to Mars but Hank the
fact of the matter is that intersex and
transsexual people have been a part of
the human species since the very
beginning of the species and none of
those theories about inborn gender
explain anything about why Chris Crocker
seems so incredibly funny or so
incredibly outrageous or so incredibly
offensive to everyone on YouTube and
Hank I have to say that even
nerdfighters like you and me aren't
completely immune to these feelings of
giggly discomfort I mean it's a little
weird that we think the baby girls like
pink and baby boys like blue when in
point of fact babies don't like any
particular color at all I mean as far as
I can tell Hank the main things that
babies like are one putting stuff in
their mouths and two pooping so anyway
Hank all of this was brewing in my mind
and then over the weekend I was watching
a video by one of our beloved secret
siblings who pointed out
that if you take a Hardy Boys book and
you add in your pants to the end of the
title it becomes unusually hilarious and
unusually high percentage of the time so
Hank without further ado I'd like to in
your pants some children's mystery
novels first we're going to go with
Nancy Drew the clue in the jewelry box
in your pants the silver cobweb in your
pants
the invisible intruder in your pants and
now hang some Hardy Boys titles the
twisted claw in your pants the hooded
hawk mystery in your pants
the masked monkey in your pants the
shattered helmet in your pants the Tower
of treasure in your pants the mystery of
the samurai sword in your pants the
stone Idol in your pants the four-headed
dragon in your pants the swamp monster
in your pants passport to danger in your
pants and of course trouble in the
pipeline in your pants now maybe I'm
looking into this a little bit too
deeply but it seems to me that long
before we hit puberty the question
actually becomes relevant ms drew and
the cousins hardy are already asking us
what are you are your clues in a jewelry
box that must be protected by silver
cobwebs from silent suspects and
invisible intruders or is your mystery a
claw or a hawk or a masked monkey or a
helmet or a tower of treasure or a
samurai sword or a stone Idol or a
four-headed dragon or a swamp monster
full of lethal cargo that is a magical
passport to danger capable of immense
foul play and dirty deeds although
sometimes there is trouble in the
pipeline hey it seems to me that in a
world that constructs gender so
dichotomously so early in life that it
makes sense that we would not
necessarily feel entirely comfortable
around people who don't fit into our
gender expectations but heck it's not
their fault that Nancy Drew and the
Hardy Boys are so incredibly weird I
think it's fine to laugh at Chris
Crocker because he cares too much about
Britney Spears but I don't think there's
anything to be gained from laughing at
him because he's different
that's the laughter that all
nerdfighters everywhere have been on the
wrong side of at least once in their
lives and I for one don't think it's
very jokes Hank I'll see you tomorrow